so those were back the other video I was
doing cut out so right now my name is
Mohammed I'm a journalist freelance
journalist so the soldier sitting behind
the car line in the ground he just like
yeah so over there he's basically a
border police
so the border police is police with
military gear mostly we have a Raja
rifle which is shoot what we call - -
and - - every time the Israeli army
saying we're not shooting library
shooting - - and tutors basically live
it's point 22 millimeter bullets it's
smaller and the user to shoot the guides
of the clashes so he's lying there
behind the car and you can see also the
thing mounted in the Jeep is called the
venom made button combined system and
they was and that thing can shoot 210
like small tear gas with less than 15
seconds I think
[Applause]
so that's an abortive police lie in the
ground with sniper and trying to shoot
the protestor over there and there's
there's Dario hey guys
it on us so fuck five words all the
sudden tears like can you explain that
to us again he was explaining to me the
difference between the soldiers and the
border police and what they're doing
right now in the clashes
so you see here like if you look like
behind the car so the one would like
dark green those are military it's
basically like soldier don't wanna go to
the front with the grey the border
police and this I have the same
privileges police also they have
military gear so they have live Amol
Grant launchers and all that so the
noises that people are hearing and we
can move a little closer can you tell us
what the different things are that are
being fired so there's the sound most of
their suit is there or politicians like
single bullets small cylinder rubber
that's have like metal side but a bit of
metal and then the other thing
you can keep lighting your cigarette
butts hello now that we're back you got
cut off in explaining the second because
we need to shoot the lab three hours of
daylight get it all in this is serial
all right I'm gonna walk over here I'm
getting really good signal right here if
you want to introduce yourself to the
audience again so they know me yeah my
name is Murphy Lance basically whenever
that they read from a lotta Israeli
police and there in front of the police
station shooting at people and they kill
someone that night so in the army left
the jeeps left like from front of the
police station signal which is when I'm
this is the only place I can get